13h30 sous un soleil radieux les uns
après les autres les bus du réseau
mozaik rentrer au dépôt un arrêt du
service public pour le moins prématurée
raison invoquée par la direction une
procédure de mise en sécurité est liée à
l' approche de la tempête
à la demande du chsct certains
chauffeurs semblent conscients des
conséquences pour les usagers c'est pas
la joie
ça aurait pas de la joie pour les gens
qui sont rares bloqué sous forme de face
mais c'est pas la joie
ça va pas être la joie pour ceux qui
sont encore au travail et qui vont
devoir se déplacer travailleurs
étudiants personnes âgées
des milliers d'usagers sont ainsi
abandonné au bord de la route par le
service public des transports
moi je pense que qu'on a été la baisse
un petit peu trop tôt il est à dire 12
est aussi notable
[Musique]
les élections qui sont à l'école comment
il faut pour sécher les daltons procès
bahia passion pour venir me chercher
comment j'ai fait circulation terminée
pour les bus mais le tcsp lui roule
encore un peu quelques rotations
supplémentaires ont été consentis
hier sans corps dévêtu la carrière et à
mao on nous a demandé exceptionnellement
le fait encore une rotation ne une fois
le trafic totalement arrêtée en fin
d'après midi
comme d'habitude c'est le système d et
la solidarité qui prennent le relais
en tout cas moi je travaille
[Musique]
non ça c'est pas normal du tout les
passagers qui sont descendus le maintien
comment il faut pouvoir monter chez eux
ce mois-ci maba tonnes de magma déposé
qu'est ce que j'allais faire simplement
un après-midi finalement bien ensoleillé
d'ailleurs la préfecture n'avait émis
aucune restriction de circulation
d'activité quant à l'autorité
organisatrice des transports
elle indique avoir appris l'arrêt du
réseau par voie de presse